well more now on our breaking news this
evening that a hundred leading doctors
uh have accused the government of
damaging the health service in a letter
to the guardian they say coalition cuts
have weakened the nhs well one of those
who signed the letter is dr claire
gerard who joins us now welcome to you
um who organized this letter
myself and some colleagues uh organized
some some medical colleagues organized
it and it is basically a vote labor
letter is it no it isn't a vote labour
it's certainly not it's a highlighting
the problems associated with this
government's handling of the nhs it's up
to the electorate to decide what uh what
they vote but it's actually pointing out
that the nhs has suffered considerably
over the last five years and if it
continues in the direction that it is we
probably won't have an nhs that's free
at the point of use and condensation
would have suffered any better or not
suffered so much under a labour
government when i'm sure the tourists
will be the first to say we're the ones
who protected the spending they would
have cut it five years ago the nhs was
performing at as the top health service
in the world it had the best health
outcomes the most equitable health
service the best value for money you
certainly can't say that's the case
today we now have as we've heard in the
news today cues uh for the general
practice which i'm a gp cues for the
emergency department we have uh
at the moment that the nhs is withering
away closure of maternity departments
walking clinics a e department it is it
is one of the few areas of government
spending over the last five years where
spending has been maintained at uh in
real terms what you have to do to
maintain a health service is actually
have what's called health inflation
because the cost of delivering health
care but you have to have the money in
the first place
and everyone else has seen cuts the
health service hasn't and yet
the health services made a number of but
also the point is labor wouldn't have
found that money they announced their
plans i'm not here to speak for or
against lay before against the
conservative government you are i mean
the letter is an attack on the
coalition's handling of the health
center isn't it sad that when one talks
about the health service now it becomes
a party political come on it's an
election campaign this is an election
letter which is done in that context nhs
has always been a political this
is document it isn't a discussion
document but it's actually
designed to make people think how
they're going to vote and it's important
that people think about how they're
going to vote with respect to the nhs
it's important that they understand
what's going on in the nhs what's going
on with the prime minister it is
something that is designed to campaign
against the coalition
as far as i'm concerned if people read
that yes then that's that's
if you say but in fact the letter is
there to lay out the problems we're
seeing with our national health system
how many of the people in the letter are
labor members no idea are you a lead
party member i am a labor party member
yes
so i'm not a labour party activist i'm
certainly not standing as a politician
but you were one of the organizers of
this yes exactly so it's organized i
mean what the conservatives is what the
conservatives are already saying my
views about the health service predated
my membership of the labour party do you
agree with that this is weaponizing the
health services i hate that word when i
was chair
when i was chair of the royal college of
gp's i was not a member of the labour
party my views then are identical to
they how they are now
this government has presided over the
dismantling the fragmentation and the
cut of the national health service we
now have a crisis a crisis not just in a
e but a crisis in general practices i
think it is the case is it not in a e as
far as the four-hour wait is concerned
that the nhs is still performing uh by
global comparison extremely well it's
remarkable how the good people who work
in the nhs have kept it together but
they're keeping it together with
sellotape and brown paper
because there's an economic crisis the
nhs is being kept together by the good
will of people like me who go and do way
over it is not being collected other
than giving you real terms medical
inflation money which seems to be not
tenable unless we're all going to pay 80
90 tax other than that what is this
government done wrong that labor would
not have done it introduced accelerated
the market the market by anybody's if
you take the increase from 4 to 6. if
you look if you look at the costs of
running the market currently government
figures are between 5 and 10 billion
pounds if you work in the health
services i do every single day including
yesterday what you see is a fragmented
chaotic health service where patients
are now having to queue for longer now i
had this when i was first started in
general performing very well
well it isn't it isn't participating
it isn't performing very well at all you
ask
the satisfaction rate it is beginning to
drop but what's holding up is the
satisfaction rate what we will see if
this continues though is we will see and
it will happen because it happens in
many marketized health services is a
rapid drop in satisfaction the poor
six percent
is marketized i mean ninety four percent
is not much i'm i don't understand the
question i'm not an economist i'm here
as you're making assertions and i'm just
saying that
only six percent of the nhs is
privatized no it's considerably more
than that if you include the pfi the
cosmic the private financial initiatives
of the building which is a labor
initiative i'm not here as a labor
parties i'm a labour party member i'm
not here saying this government has run
the nhs into the group can i finish
answering your question if you take into
account all the outsourced jobs now a
lot of the portering the catering uh the
transport for the nhs is significantly
more than six percent of the nhs has
been privatized so you think that the
catering for example should be
nationalized
i was just answering your question
there's there's a lot do i think the
coaching of the nhs should be should be
nationalized i think we should have a
long hard look at what the cost has been
of the marketization the the
privatization the dna
from your long experience in the nhs has
been introduced by successive
governments of either color of course it
has this is not party political of
course it has in fact a pfi was
accelerated by the last labour
government it was begun by the
prehistory government so of course so